un bordel de merde
je n'ai jamais vu une chose pareille de
merde
c'est la chose la plus folle que j'ai
jamais vu
merde 11 millions de dollars
avec nous
quoi de neuf les amis ici je vais
choisir une action et vous expliquer
pourquoi elle est intéressante et
l'action choisie est game stop j'adore
ce gars
[Applaudissements]
il pense que c'est un bon investissement
un seul gars semble contrôler tous les
achats c'est qui ce petit con un petit
investisseur stupide je vais pas cracher
dessus
Paris sur le fait que cette entreprise
va échouer et si elle plonge c'est
spéculatifs vont se faire une
petite fortune 70
000 personnes ont vu cette vidéo
[Musique]
il y va j'y vais si il y va
continue de grimper cette action va
faire que monter quand elle sera tout en
haut je t'achèterai un
palaceur ne peut pas se tromper
de merde est-ce que tu as une minute
combien on a fait aujourd'hui chérie
5 millions combien on a perdu
aujourd'hui un milliard et hier 4
millions et hier combien un milliard
vraiment
il y a un paquet de riches qui doivent
se pisser dessus ils vont tous s'en
prendre à toi monsieur on doit parler du
problème game stop les petits
investisseurs perdent toujours il vous
poursuivre
de voir témoigner devant le Congrès le
jeu a changé
[Musique]
ta récompense le coup pense que le
système est corrompu l'idée derrière la
bourse c'est que si tu es intelligent et
que tu as en plus un peu de chance tu
peux faire fortune c'est vrai mon plus
grand
il y a aucun espoir pour les petits
[Musique]
mais maintenant ça pourrait changer mais
toi
[Musique]